gameplay of Assassin's Creed codenamed
Jade has reportedly surfaced online this
gameplay which we can't show in this
video features the game's combat and
traversal as well as a cut scene despite
the game being slated for a mobile
release the alleged gameplay looks just
like you would expect in Assassin's
Creed console release to look the HUD
does appear to include some on-screen
controls though however if touch
controls aren't your thing I'm sure
that's something that a Bluetooth
controller or something like a backbone
controller can fix codename Jade is set
in China but fans won't be seeing the
return of the protagonist from AC
Chronicles China instead Jade will
feature a completely new character who
is reportedly fully customizable at this
time the game does not have any type of
release date information available but
if I were to guess based on the alleged
gameplay I'd guess it's not super far
off at this point don't recall Jade even
getting announced well that might be
because it was stuffed into an AC
showcase case earlier this year
alongside the announcement of AC Mirage
codename red and codename hex red will
take place in Japan while hex appears to
have a Blair Witch Vibe and remains a
mystery none of these games have release
information either but earlier this
month there were rumors of Mirage
looking at an August launch according to
Insider gaming the game has already been
delayed internally twice but Ubisoft
planned for it to come out earlier in
2023 while you wait for those AC
experiences to become available why not
jump into The Witcher 3 wild Hunt the
2015 game just got a tightly anticipated
next-gen update that added Ray tracing a
photo mode new camera options and more
unfortunately for PC players the update
was a bit broken causing many to revert
their version of the game to a previous
version CD projekt Red promised to solve
the issues and today the game received
its first hotfix on PC since the release
of the 4.0 update the fix weighs in at
about two gigs on Steam and on Twitter
the dev said it should quote improve the
overall stability and performance and
fix Gog and steam overlays the game
version won't change I've already
downloaded the fix and so far so good on
Steam deck I'm mainly replaying the game
on PS5 but one of the new features is
cross save so I've been going back and
forth between that and the deck before
the game suddenly started crashing on
the handheld and speaking of a game that
crashes on a handheld device let's talk
about Pokemon scarlet and Violet's next
raid according to serebii.net the
upcoming Seven Star Terror Raid Battle
will be a fighting Terror type cinderace
which is normally just a cool fire type
that looks like it loves soccer the site
says the event will take place 4 pm
Pacific 7 PM Eastern on December 29th
through December 31st at 3 59 PM Pacific
or 6 59 Eastern and if you're busy
celebrating the holidays and you miss it
you'll have another chance between
January 12th and January 14th hit the
comment section and let me know if you
got the Charizard from the last event an
event that I unfortunately missed and
we'll see you in the next one